Elon Musk push for transparency tainted
by a top lawyer inside Twitter the
billionaire firing the company's legal
counsel James Baker for going behind his
back and secretly vetting the Twitter
files before their release this
intervention slowed the process of
getting the information out to the
public the New York Post calls it an
inside job and if you thought Jim Baker
was a familiar name well he used to work
for the FBI as general counsel under
James Comey and was a central figure to
the Russia investigation Baker also
played a hand in censoring the hunter
Biden laptop story As the World Turns of
course Republicans are calling on top
Twitter Executives to testify and Jim
Jordan thinks that what happened helped
President Biden to get elected
big Tech big government big media all
colluding to keep valuable information
from we the people and of course John we
know the consequences of all this are
that Joe Biden was president became
president and we have 41-year high
inflation a border that's no longer a
border rampant crime and all the other
problems we see with with this
Administration not least of which is the
FBI has been weaponized against we the
people and is no longer treating
Americans equally under the law and the
White House still staying tight-lipped
about the revelations
did anyone from the Biden team
communicate to Twitter that this
material was was from hap or this
reporting stem from hacked materials I
can't speak to decisions made by uh by
the campaign from here that is not it is
a political uh campaign but what I can
say more broadly is of course it's up to
these companies to make their own
decision about the content on their
platforms and to ensure content follows
their own standards and policies I was a
little surprised Jesse to find out that
James Baker actually still worked for
Twitter given that Elon Musk cleaned a
lot of the house before he even got
started yeah you don't like to clean
house with the lawyers first because
they know a lot and but he stuck his
neck out there and then he got exited I
love that term he got exited he's a
fixer he doesn't have legal chops he was
a Bag Man for crooked at the FBI then he
went to the other side to run
interference for the Biden campaign at
Twitter and you don't have to be a good
lawyer to succeed in this country you
just have to be able to do political
favors for people that's how you ascend
now you do political favors as a lawyer
and lawyers are destroying this country
everywhere you look
on this stupid warrant on the Trump
campaign who is his Deputy Kleinfeld
fabricated the documents to get the
lawyer avenatti lawyers because they're
doing legal business why don't you talk
about others they're doing political
business they're not doing legal
business another one avenatti remember
him he's a great guy also who was it
Mark Elias he loosened all of the
election laws that allowed for all of
these paper to blast out touch your
hands very well you watch your hand
Geraldo Sussman again Adam Schiff
everywhere you turn the country's trying
to move and there's a stupid Democrat
lawyer cutting your knees out from under
you Hunter's a lawyer there you go yeah
I guarantee you Satan went to law school
also that's why you can't get anything
done in this country anytime you try to
build something frivolous lawsuit
they're actually suing TGI Fridays
because there's cheddar in the
mozzarella sticks they that's why
everybody hates these people I have a
proposal how
all the Lord s in America take a
vacation next year
okay one year all the lawyers stopped
their practice I guarantee you this
country would be like paradise but if
you ever notice something oh yeah who
makes money in Conflict three Industries
arms dealers the media and lawyers
they're cleaning up because they bill by
the hour you Bill you Bill and we all
pay because the more conflict there is
the more money you shell out and all our
lawyers lose our lawyers get their homes
rated their office is rated their iPhone
sees constantly you're on the back end
you put in your water today
not enough Geraldo I swear to God and I
think the Biden families being
blackmailed by the FBI because when the
FBI teams up with the lawyers
hell on Earth can I can I bring it back
that was the best Jesse Waters
impersonation I've ever heard by you
Jesse I had it I aside from first we
killed the lawyers the the thing that
bothers me Jim Jordan what he said
that's what bothers me about this whole
Twitter story The implication is that
because Twitter didn't go all out to
back the New York Post therefore the
election was somehow flawed therefore
the election was flawed so the president
Trump is Justified in uh in saying that
the election was uh you know uh not
legitimate we can take whatever means
necessary suspend the Constitution it is
absolutely absurd to think that because
one media Outlet Twitter didn't back the
New York Post therefore the election is
flawed I mean it's it's an assumption
built on an assumption built on
something everybody could follow them
and Facebook and everybody did and they
stopped conversations
I don't know I don't know if it imperil
the election because I'm not a
statistician there was one survey that
said it that yeah that ten percent of it
it would have changed the election
there's no question there are studies
that out there here's the bottom line
forget about all this garbage with
lawyers okay you know if there weren't
any lawyers first of all every criminal
that's in jail would be out of jail
right now I don't think that would make
you very happy and chances are if there
weren't any lawyers and if you got hurt
and you were fighting your neighbor you
wouldn't be able to sue your neighbor
all that stuff you wouldn't be able to
that wouldn't be a frivolous lawsuit you
wouldn't be that would be a righteous
loss look I want to talk about this this
guy James Baker is as deep State as you
can get he was involved in the Russia
collusion delusion okay he's involved in
Twitter and you know why they found out
about him because Miranda Divine to her
credit said where are the emails that
show that the FBI was communicating with
Twitter but for Miranda Devine and good
for you Miranda they would not have
found the emails where this guy James
Baker is a professional at making sure
that the government influences politics
and influences policy in the United
States and it amazes me that someone who
is a lawyer is so antithetical
everything he thinks is opposite the
First Amendment and Free Speech I'm
talking about James Baker the lawyer for
the FBI the lawyer at Twitter I mean who
thinks in those terms to me he was just
trying to cover his ass it seems he
wasn't coming that's why he wasn't
released
you know oh really there's a
justification I'm not saying it's the
right thing I don't care what's the
reason was the guy's a crook he should
have been prosecuted for the Russian
delusion
he was fired right and you know what he
should have been prosecuted you finished
I'm pretty sure okay let's turn it over
to you well okay so I will go and talk
briefly about the media and I because I
I enjoy watching on Twitter how the
reporters going after the reporters for
reporting the news as if this isn't news
and so what they're doing is they're
acting like
they're acting like the media is on
strike and when you do this story you're
a scab so Matt taibi is a scab and I was
thinking like that's actually true for a
lot of things like I was thinking about
this like the media goes on strike
regarding specific stories that we cover
that the stories that they don't like
the the stuff the the uh the laptop
story if you look at the border if you
look at crime if you if you do those
stories if you follow up on like I don't
know gender affirmation surgeries if you
do that they're gonna the media is gonna
go after you and basically treat you
like a scab I feel I mean when you do
when you see these correspondence
dinners you get that Vibe even though we
crush them in the ratings everybody
there thinks that you've like crossed
the picket line because you're doing
stories that make the mainstream media
uncomfortable so if that's a scab then
pick us yeah yeah all right